Think about your day for a second.
You woke up, felt fresh air on your face
as you walked out the door,
encountered new colleagues
and had great discussions
and felt in awe
when you found something new.
But I bet there's something
you didn't think about today,
something so close to home,
you probably don't think
about it very often at all.
And that's that all those sensations,
feelings, decisions and actions
are mediated by the computer in your head
called your brain.
Now, the brain may not look
like much from the outside --
a couple pounds of pinkish-gray flesh,
amorphous.
But the last 100 years of neuroscience
have allowed us to zoom in on the brain
and to see the intricacy
of what lies within.
And they've told us that this brain
is an incredibly complicated circuit
made out of hundreds of billions
of cells called neurons.
Now, unlike a human-designed computer,
where there's a fairly small number
of different parts,
and we know how they work
because we humans designed them,
the brain is made out of thousands
of different kinds of cells,
maybe tens of thousands.
They come in different shapes;
they're made out of different molecules;
they project and connect
to different brain regions.
They also change in different ways
in different disease states.
Let's make it concrete.
There's a class of cells,
a fairly small cell, an inhibitory cell,
that quiets its neighbors.
It's one of the cells
that seems to be atrophied
in disorders like schizophrenia.
It's called the basket cell.
And this cell is one
of the thousands of kinds of cell
that we're learning about.
New ones are being discovered every day.
As just a second example:
these pyramidal cells, large cells,
can span a significant fraction
of the brain.
They're excitatory.
And these are some of the cells
that might be overactive
in disorders such as epilepsy.
Every one of these cells
is an incredible electrical device.
They receive inputs
from thousands of upstream partners
and compute their own electrical outputs,
which then, if they pass
a certain threshold,
will go to thousands
of downstream partners.
And this process, which takes
just a millisecond or so,
happens thousands of times a minute
in every one of your 100 billion cells,
as long as you live and think and feel.
So how are we going to figure out
what this circuit does?
Ideally, we could go through this circuit
and turn these different
kinds of cell on and off
and see whether we could figure out
which ones contribute to certain functions
and which ones go wrong
in certain pathologies.
If we could activate cells, we could see
what powers they can unleash,
what they can initiate and sustain.
If we could turn them off,
then we could try and figure out
what they're necessary for.
And that's the story
I'm going to tell you about today.
And honestly, where we've gone
through over the last 11 years,
through an attempt to find ways
of turning circuits and cells
and parts and pathways of the brain
on and off,
both to understand the science
and also to confront some of the issues
that face us all as humans.
Now, before I tell you
about the technology,
the bad news is that a significant
fraction of us in this room,
if we live long enough,
will encounter, perhaps, a brain disorder.
Already, a billion people
have had some kind of brain disorder
that incapacitates them.
The numbers don't do it justice, though.
These disorders --
schizophrenia, Alzheimer's,
depression, addiction --
they not only steal away our time to live,
they change who we are.
They take our identity
and change our emotions
and change who we are as people.
Now, in the 20th century,
there was some hope that was generated
through the development of pharmaceuticals
for treating brain disorders.
And while many drugs have been developed
that can alleviate symptoms
of brain disorders,
practically none of them
can be considered to be cured.
In part, that's because,
if you think about it,
we're bathing the brain in a chemical --
this elaborate circuit, made of thousands
of different kinds of cell --
is being bathed in a substance.
That's also why most of the drugs,
not all, on the market
can present some kind
of serious side effect too.
Now some people have gotten some solace
from electrical stimulators
that are implanted in the brain,
for Parkinson's disease
or cochlear implants.
These have indeed been able
to bring some kind of remedy
to people with certain kinds of disorders.
But electricity also will go
in all directions --
the path of least resistance --
which is where that phrase,
in part, comes from,
and will also affect normal circuits,
as well as the abnormal ones
you want to fix.
So again, we're sent back to the idea
of ultraprecise control:
Could we dial in information
precisely where we want it to go?
So, when I started
in neuroscience 11 years ago --
I had trained as an electrical
engineer and a physicist --
the first thing I thought about was,
if these neurons are electrical devices,
all we need to do is to find some way
of driving those electrical changes
at a distance.
If we could turn on the electricity
in one cell but not its neighbors,
that'd give us the tool to activate
and shut down these different cells
to figure out what they do
and how they contribute
to the networks in which they're embedded.
It would also allow us to have
the ultraprecise control we need
to fix the circuit computations
that have gone awry.
Now, how are we going to do that?
Well, there are many molecules
that exist in nature
which are able to convert
light into electricity.
You can think of them as little proteins
that are like solar cells.
If we install these molecules
in neurons somehow,
then these neurons would become
electrically drivable with light,
and their neighbors, which don't have
this molecule, would not.
There's one other magic trick you need
to make this happen:
the ability to get light into the brain.
The brain doesn't feel pain.
Taking advantage of all the effort
that's gone into the internet,
telecommunications, etc.,
you can put optical fibers
connected to lasers
to activate -- in animal models,
for example, in preclinical studies --
these neurons and see what they do.
So how do we do this?
Around 2004, in collaboration
with Georg Nagel and Karl Deisseroth,
this vision came to fruition.
There's a certain alga
that swims in the wild,
and it needs to navigate towards light
in order to photosynthesize optimally.
And it senses light with a little eyespot,
which works not unlike how our eye works.
In its membrane, or its boundary,
it contains little proteins
that indeed can convert
light into electricity.
These molecules are called
channelrhodopsins.
And each of these proteins
acts just like that solar cell
that I told you about.
When blue light hits it,
it opens a little hole and allows
charged particles to enter the eyespot;
that allows this eyespot
to have an electrical signal,
just like a solar cell charging a battery.
So what we need to do
is take these molecules
and somehow install them in neurons.
And because it's a protein,
it's encoded for
in the DNA of this organism.
So all we've got to do is take that DNA,
put it into a gene therapy
vector, like a virus,
and put it into neurons.
And this was a very productive time
in gene therapy,
and lots of viruses were coming along,
so this turned out to be fairly simple.
Early in the morning
one day in the summer of 2004,
we gave it a try,
and it worked on the first try.
You take this DNA
and put it into the neuron.
The neuron uses its natural
protein-making machinery
to fabricate these little
light-sensitive proteins
and install them all over the cell,
like putting solar panels on a roof.
And the next thing you know,
you have a neuron
which can be activated with light.
So this is very powerful.
One of the tricks you have to do
is figure out how to deliver these genes
to the cells you want
and not all the other neighbors.
And you can do that;
you can tweak the viruses
so they hit some cells and not others.
And there's other genetic
tricks you can play
in order to get light-activated cells.
This field has now come to be known
as "optogenetics."
And just as one example
of the kind of thing you can do,
you can take a complex network,
use one of these viruses
to deliver the gene
just to one kind of cell
in this dense network.
And then when you shine light
on the entire network,
just that cell type will be activated.
For example, let's consider
that basket cell I told you about earlier,
the one that's atrophied in schizophrenia
and the one that is inhibitory.
If we can deliver that gene
to these cells --
they won't be altered by the expression
of the gene, of course --
then flash blue light
over the entire brain network,
just these cells are going to be driven.
And when the light turns off,
these cells go back to normal;
there don't seem to be adverse events.
Not only can you study
what these cells do,
what their power
is in computing in the brain,
you can also use this to try to figure out
if we could jazz up
the activity of these cells
if indeed, they're atrophied.
I want to tell you some short stories
about how we're using this
both at the scientific clinical
and preclinical levels.
One of the questions
that we've confronted is:
What signals in the brain
mediate the sensation of reward?
Because if you could find those,
those would be some of the signals
that could drive learning;
the brain will do more
of what got that reward.
These are also signals that go awry
in disorders such as addiction.
So if we could figure out what cells
they are, we could maybe find new targets
for which drugs can be
designed or screened against
or maybe places
where electrodes could be put in
for people who have severe disability.
To do that, we came up with
a very simple paradigm
in collaboration with the Fiorillo group,
where, if the animal goes
to one side of this little box,
it gets a pulse of light.
And we'll make different cells
in the brain sensitive to light.
If these cells can mediate reward,
the animal should go there more and more.
And that's what happens.
The animal goes to the right-hand side
and pokes his nose there
and gets a flash of blue light
every time he does it.
He'll do that hundreds of times.
These are the dopamine neurons,
in some of the pleasure
centers in the brain.
We've shown that a brief activation
of these is enough to drive learning.
Now we can generalize the idea.
Instead of one point in the brain,
we can devise devices that span the brain,
that can deliver light
into three-dimensional patterns --
arrays of optical fibers,
each coupled to its own independent
miniature light source.
Then we can try to do things in vivo
that have only been done
to date in a dish,
like high-throughput screening
throughout the entire brain
for the signals that can cause
certain things to happen
or that could be good clinical targets
for treating brain disorders.
One story I want to tell you about is:
How can we find targets for treating
post-traumatic stress disorder,
a form of uncontrolled anxiety and fear?
One of the things that we did was to adopt
a very classical model of fear.
This goes back to the Pavlovian days.
It's called Pavlovian fear conditioning,
where a tone ends with a brief shock.
The shock isn't painful,
but it's a little annoying.
And over time -- in this case, a mouse,
which is a good animal model,
commonly used in such experiments --
the animal learns to fear the tone.
It will react by freezing,
sort of like a deer in the headlights.
Now the question is: What targets
in the brain can we find
that allow us to overcome this fear?
So we play that tone again,
after it's been associated with fear.
But we activate
different targets in the brain,
using that optical fiber array
I showed on the previous slide,
in order to try and figure out
which targets can cause the brain
to overcome that memory of fear.
This brief video shows you
one of these targets
that we're working on now.
This is an area in the prefrontal cortex,
a region where we can use cognition
to try to overcome
aversive emotional states.
The animal hears a tone.
A flash of light occurs.
There's no audio, but you see
that the animal freezes --
the tone used to mean bad news.
There's a little clock
in the lower left-hand corner.
You can see the animal
is about two minutes into this.
This next clip
is just eight minutes later.
And the same tone is going to play,
and the light is going to flash again.
OK, there it goes. Right ... now.
And now you can see,
just 10 minutes into the experiment,
that we've equipped the brain,
by photoactivating this area,
to overcome the expression
of this fear memory.
Over the last couple years,
we've gone back to the tree of life,
because we wanted to find ways
to turn circuits in the brain off.
If we could do that,
this could be extremely powerful.
If you can delete cells
for a few milliseconds or seconds,
you can figure out what role they play
in the circuits in which they're embedded.
We surveyed organisms
from all over the tree of life --
every kingdom of life but animals;
we see slightly differently.
We found molecules called
halorhodopsins or archaerhodopsins,
that respond to green and yellow light.
And they do the opposite
of the molecule I told you about before,
with the blue light activator,
channelrhodopsin.
Let's give an example
of where we think this is going to go.
Consider, for example,
a condition like epilepsy,
where the brain is overactive.
Now, if drugs fail in epileptic treatment,
one of the strategies
is to remove part of the brain,
but that's irreversible,
and there could be side effects.
What if we could just turn off that brain
for the brief amount of time
until the seizure dies away,
and cause the brain to be restored
to its initial state,
like a dynamical system that's being
coaxed down into a stable state?
This animation tries
to explain this concept
where we made these cells sensitive
to being turned off with light,
and we beam light in,
and just for the time it takes
to shut down a seizure,
we're hoping to be able to turn it off.
We don't have data
to show you on this front,
but we're very excited about this.
I want to close on one story,
which we think is another possibility,
which is that maybe these molecules,
if you can do ultraprecise control,
can be used in the brain itself
to make a new kind of prosthetic,
an optical prosthetic.
I already told you that electrical
stimulators are not uncommon.
Seventy-five thousand people
have Parkinson's deep-brain
stimulators implanted,
maybe 100,000 people have cochlear
implants, which allow them to hear.
Another thing -- you've got
to get these genes into cells.
A new hope in gene therapy
has been developed,
because viruses like
the adeno-associated virus --
which probably most of us
around this room have;
it doesn't have any symptoms --
have been used in hundreds of patients
to deliver genes
into the brain or the body.
And so far, there have not been
serious adverse events
associated with the virus.
There's one last elephant
in the room: the proteins themselves,
which come from algae,
bacteria and funguses
and all over the tree of life.
Most of us don't have funguses
or algae in our brains,
so what will our brain do
if we put that in?
Will the cells tolerate it?
Will the immune system react?
It's early -- these haven't
been done in humans yet --
but we're working on a variety
of studies to examine this.
So far, we haven't seen
overt reactions of any severity
to these molecules
or to the illumination
of the brain with light.
So it's early days, to be upfront,
but we're excited about it.
I wanted to close with one story,
which we think could potentially
be a clinical application.
Now, there are many forms of blindness
where the photoreceptors --
light sensors in the back of our eye --
are gone.
And the retina is a complex structure.
Let's zoom in on it
so we can see it in more detail.
The photoreceptor cells
are shown here at the top.
The signals that are detected
by the photoreceptors are transformed
via various computations
until finally, the layer of cells
at the bottom, the ganglion cells,
relay the information to the brain,
where we see that as perception.
In many forms of blindness,
like retinitis pigmentosa
or macular degeneration,
the photoreceptor cells
have atrophied or been destroyed.
Now, how could you repair this?
It's not even clear that a drug
could cause this to be restored,
since there's nothing
for the drug to bind to.
On the other hand,
light can still get into the eye.
The eye is still transparent
and you can get light in.
So what if we could take these
channelrhodopsins and other molecules
and install them
on some of these other spared cells
and convert them into little cameras?
And because there are so many
of these cells in the eye,
potentially, they could be
very high-resolution cameras.
This is some work that we're doing,
led by one of our collaborators,
Alan Horsager at USC,
and being sought to be commercialized
by a start-up company, Eos Neuroscience,
which is funded by the NIH.
What you see here is a mouse
trying to solve a six-arm maze.
There's a bit of water to motivate
the mouse to move or he'll just sit there.
The goal of this maze
is to get out of the water
and go to a little platform
that's under the lit top port.
Mice are smart, so this one
solves the maze eventually,
but he does a brute-force search.
He's swimming down every avenue
until he finally gets to the platform.
He's not using vision to do it.
These different mice
are different mutations
that recapitulate different kinds
of blindness that affect humans.
So we're being careful in trying
to look at these different models
so we come up with a generalized approach.
So how can we solve this?
We'll do exactly what we outlined
in the previous slide.
We'll take these blue light photo sensors
and install them onto a layer of cells
in the middle of the retina
in the back of the eye
and convert them into a camera --
just like installing solar cells
all over those neurons
to make them light-sensitive.
Light is converted to electricity on them.
So this mouse was blind
a couple weeks before this experiment
and received one dose of this
photosensitive molecule on a virus.
And now you can see,
the animal can indeed avoid walls
and go to this little platform
and make cognitive use of its eyes again.
And to point out the power of this:
these animals can get to that platform
just as fast as animals
that have seen their entire lives.
So this preclinical study,
I think, bodes hope
for the kinds of things
we're hoping to do in the future.
We're also exploring new business models
for this new field of neurotechnology.
We're developing tools
and sharing them freely
with hundreds of groups all over the world
for them to study and try
to treat different disorders.
Our hope is that
by figuring out brain circuits
at a level of abstraction that lets us
repair them and engineer them,
we can take some of these intractable
disorders I mentioned earlier,
practically none of which are cured,
and in the 21st century,
make them history.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Juan Enriquez: So some of this stuff
is a little dense.
(Laughter)
But the implications of being able
to control seizures or epilepsy
with light instead of drugs
and being able to target
those specifically
is a first step.
The second thing
that I think I heard you say
is you can now control
the brain in two colors,
like an on-off switch.
Ed Boyden: That's right.
JE: Which makes every impulse going
through the brain a binary code.
EB: Right.
With blue light, we can drive information,
and it's in the form of a one.
And by turning things off,
it's more or less a zero.
Our hope is to eventually build brain
coprocessors that work with the brain
so we can augment functions
in people with disabilities.
JE: And in theory, that means that,
as a mouse feels, smells, hears, touches,
you can model it out
as a string of ones and zeros.
EB: Yeah. We're hoping
to use this as a way of testing
what neural codes
can drive certain behaviors
and certain thoughts and certain feelings
and use that to understand
more about the brain.
JE: Does that mean that someday
you could download memories
and maybe upload them?
EB: That's something we're starting
to work on very hard.
We're now working on trying to tile
the brain with recording elements, too,
so we can record information
and then drive information back in --
sort of computing what the brain needs
in order to augment
its information processing.
JE: Well, that might change
a couple things. Thank you.
EB: Thank you.
(Applause)